[Music]
stack them up high enough why do you
play the pirate when you're not a pirate
why don't we get [ __ ] fire how come
you don't have the wood leg
[Applause]
you edit while you shoot are you already
thinking of the shots that you want I'm
not even thinking about your special
Mike's gonna put them thinking about
German fights gonna take me to stick it
with these put these show business
stories
you know bill do you just work or do you
wait for something to strike a chord
with you in a passionate type I do I do
I think about you know what kind of
springboards this work could take us to
do you stay away from hot-button topics
or you just steer that ship right into
it yeah sass I Drive right into it right
into the middle if they're okay wait
Neil deGrasse Tyson he's met in trouble
around
I studied last night
find out without staring at you he's a
really good friend
we know you
[Music]
[Applause]
just
we had last night had a great time
today's March 2nd 2019 my 27 year
anniversary
a comedian that's what kills me now when
I meet young comics so my debit doesn't
comment comedy for this person more than
this person's a bit of life
[Music]
it's a potassium I think I'm gonna say I
need potassium just so you guys can all
right but actually you don't want me to
potassium that's like the worst thing
you could do
[Music]
go [ __ ] yourself happy Anniversary to me
work here which could you move your
[ __ ] ambulance please it's an
emergency
alright so I been to this one before
this is the Apollo Theater and not
Manchester I want to say to New
Hampshire Manchester England this is a
fun fun [ __ ] place I've discovered
I'm not dehydrated I have a stomach
virus something I [ __ ] ate Liverpool
I believe I'm blaming Liverpool that
first place we were at that [ __ ]
restaurant where everything they made
was horrific so on stage last night I
almost fainted [ __ ] like five times
this is their Gatorade
lucozade lucozade Lucas a taste like
[ __ ]
[Applause]
how much [ __ ] fun was that dude
Manchester the problem it's just [ __ ]
yesterday that place is like is magic I
was thinking about my special a little
too much during it thinking about a joke
that I wanted to flip I I tried to say
to the end I hope but that I mentioned
how cool it is to perform here you know
like it's great like I can't imagine
yeah I just remembered not being able to
sell tickets in a comedy club forget
about [ __ ] coming this far away so
now I get to drive down to London and go
see my family I'm so [ __ ] excited
[Applause]
[Music]